Your eyes are the
color of...
...Really pretty eyes.
Oh, your skin is like
a milk-fed piglet.
Oh, I wish we could
sail away together.
Me too.
Faster, boy. I want to feel
the wind in my hair.
(Dodo)
Why are you two lawn boating?
Afternoons are for defecating
and learning Latin.
Mother, we can't work
all the time.
Frederick, put on
a clean top hat.
I've invited a widow
to the manor
in hopes of making a match.
Frederick
will never get married.
All the women Mother's brought
so far have either left
or had accidents.
Pussy Von Anderstein's former
husband was a coon-tie tycoon.
He made a fortune designing
raccoon-skin neckties,
and as long as you don't do
anything stupid,
that fortune will be ours.
But we have
infinite money!
Yes, if we have infinite money
and we add Pussy money to it,
we have double infinite money.
But, Mother,
infinity can't be doubled,
as its very nature is
its boundlessness.
It frightens me when you
act all smart like that.
Look, the day moon!
Frederick,
you must take a wife.
You're 23 years old.
Mother, I'm 35.
You're what?
Yes. Right?
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
[hip-hop music]